was unveiling a company-wide effort this
morning to raise awareness of sexual
assault it is revamping how it handles
customer complaints lubbers faces
multiple allegations of criminal
behavior bus drivers reported culture of
harassment inside the company led to the
resignation of its founder Travis
kalanick as CEO uber said the new
initiative will make it easier for
riders to share their stories in Johanna
Diaz is inside ubers largest call center
in Phoenix Arizona he'd ran a good
morning good morning we're the first TV
news organization allowed into obras
call center which operates 24 hours a
day if a rider or driver reports a
serious issue on the uber app it ends up
here and one of these employees will
call to follow up now the company wants
to do more it's adding new sensitivity
training to improve those calls with
victims I pushed him off me he came at
me again and did the same thing shoved
his tongue in my mouth last summer a
nighttime ride turned into a nightmare
when 43 year old Chris bricks said her
uber driver attacked her she reported it
and an uber rep called her within hours
it almost seems like a little bit
dismissive I never even found out if the
driver was still on the road but now
Ebers trying to improve the experience
victims have with call center employees
when they're receiving a call of this
nature it's critically important how we
respond and that that could be
life-changing for that person Tracy
Breeden who runs global safety
communications says they're giving
employees additional sensitivity
training for speaking with trauma
victims see thank you for sharing this
with us thank you for sharing that
information with being we witnessed a
call take place with a driver who said
she was inappropriately touched by a
rider so your training has taught you to
approach these people how
to approach them from an outsider stance
to where people feel like they can have
trust in the person that they're talking
to but some riders like bricks say the
company needs to go even further adding
an in-app panic button cameras and cars
and fingerprint-based background checks
for drivers the company doesn't have
plans to make those changes but today
they are sending out information on
sexual assault prevention to riders and
drivers through their app well drivers
be required to read this in order to be
approved to drive right now at this time
they receive the information we're
hopeful that they'll all look at it why
not do a sexual assault training like a
lot of companies do you have to think
these are independent contractors and so
we can provide information we provide
tips we provide educational resources we
can do things like that and that's
something we do on a regular basis
people filing complaints still have to
be the ones to follow up with uber if
they want to know how their case was
resolved now if you use the uber app
chances are today you'll receive a
message from a company with a link to
information from sexual assault
awareness groups uber is donating 5
million dollars to those groups as part
of a new partnership Nora all right and
you're gonna thank you I'm glad to see
that they're being proactive on this
yeah all right I'm taking it seriously
and that's very important great